australia-wide dog the dingo is on the
prowl
today it hunts alone a sign that dingo
is probably on the lookout for small
game but it senses a larger opportunity
a baby kangaroo called a Joey makes an
excellent target it's too big for his
mother to carry if she has to run away
the dingo slinks forward while the Joey
unaware keeps busy grooming himself his
mother senses a nearby predator but it's
not the dingo her attention is fixed on
the wedge tailed eagle flying above his
mother calls Joey to her side
[Music]
neither one sees the dingo approaching
through the brush for a moment a young
male freezes Hispanic feeds contagious
the mother and her Joey make their
getaway to the dingo bursts after the
ruse the dingoes no slouch when it comes
to speed but the ruse reached 35 miles
per hour
dingoes have better luck hunting in
packs when they're after large kangaroos
it's back to searching for prey that's
not so big and not so fast